on November 28th Nancy Pelosi cleared a
major hurdle in her quest to become
Speaker of the House for the second time
what do all Americans think about her
and what about Democrats in November
Gallup reported that Pelosi has long
been viewed more negatively than
positively in the organization's latest
2018 poll 29% had a favorable opinion of
her and 53% unfavorable one should she
be speaker again when the party takes
control in January in the mid November
CBS News poll 30 percent nationally said
that they would prefer Pelosi to be the
next speaker and 57% another Democrat 49
percent of Democrats preferred her and
40 percent another Democrat in a late
November Harvard Harris online survey 33
percent nationally said that the house
should reelect her while 67 percent said
it was time for a new leader Democrats
preferred a new leader by a slim margin
52 to 48 percent Pelosi is formidable
but it's clear there is an appetite for
change among Democrats should Nancy
Pelosi be speaker for a second time let
us know in our poll also let us know
what other topics you'd like our
scholars to cover in 60 seconds and be
sure to LIKE and subscribe for more
research and videos from AEI